- On this episode, I talk about
the edge or the center,
selling cats,
and jabs and right hooks.
(bell rings)
(heavy hip-hop music)
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show.
Welcome to Episode 8 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Eight - a little fun
fact for that number is
that is Broadway Browning Nagle's number.
Look it up.
- [Voiceover] Erik asks, "Do you
believe in Jim Collins' belief
that you can only focus on three things?"
Erik, as a very underread,
undereducated gentleman,
I don't know all the details
of Mr. Collins' three
things that we can focus
or the thesis behind it
but I will tell you that
I'm a contradiction on this question.
Oftentimes I think that
if you're doing more than one thing,
you're not doing anything,
and so when I focus on
building businesses,
I try to focus on one core
thing, but look at me right now,
I've never been busier in my life
and I've decided to
start another video show?
Here's my theory: focus on one thing,
and make that 80-90% of your nut,
and then have 20%, 10-20%
of complete and utter chaos
trying things, probably losing
because you're not focused on them,
but it keeps life spicy and interesting.
That's what works for me.
The truth is, I have a feeling this works
very differently for everyone.
- [Voiceover] Corey asks,
"What's the best way
to grow a following or a
community from nothing?"
Corey, this is easy for me to answer,
since I've done it a couple of times,
and the real answer is,
content and context.
My belief is the best way to
build a following right now
is to put out daily, if you can, content
and get as close to
that as possible, right,
and so, every day, put out your picture
or your drawing on your
Snapchat that you blast out
or your Instagram photos
or your video show
or whatever you may be
doing. Your written blog,
every day. You know?
Six days is better than five days,
and five days is better than four days,
and four days is better than three days,
and two days is better
than one day a week.
But if you're doing it one
or two or three days a week,
are you really doing it?
And so pumping out hardcore content,
and then engaging.
I'm going to ask a
Question of the Day today,
and hopefully, after I get
home at 11:30, twelve tonight,
I'm gonna go into the comments
and reply to some of those answers,
creating context.
You've empowered me by watching my show,
I then jumped back in to answer
your Question of the Day answer,
showing you that I appreciate you.
We've created a deeper context,
just like when I reply to
you or I answer your email
or some of the Cyber Dusts
I've done in the last 24 hours,
it's about content and context.
Building a community takes work.
Building a community is
not a foregone conclusion.
Everybody just thinks
you're gonna start a show
and everything's gonna magically happen,
or you're gonna start a blog
or you're gonna become
an Instagram sensation.
The talent to put out the content
is only one piece of the equation.
1% of the magic 1%, get it
just by the content push-out,
but for the rest of us
chaps and chapettes,
we've gotta put in the
work into the community
and care back to the
time they've allocated.
The fact that people are spending
ten minutes to watch this
in your ridiculously busy world
is something I will never,
ever take for granted.
- [Voiceover] Jon asks, "tea or coffee? Or wine?"
Jon, the answer these days is water.
But, you know, overall,
you know, it's funny,
I would say tea, and it's wine.
It's wine, out of those beverages.
Now, root beer would have
been more interesting,
but I would say it goes wine, tea, coffee.
- [Voiceover] Eric asks,
"As a business leader,
what's the one thing that
keeps you up at night?"
Eric, this is interesting.
I promised myself when I started this show
that I would go really direct, right?
I mean, I already have the benefit
of Steve picking the questions, so,
meaning that, you know,
there's no reason not to go
direct and honest on these.
This is gonna be a little
bit of a douchey answer,
so DRock, I know you know how to edit,
can you create a little
douche alert thing here?
Can we get some sirens going.
(sirens blaring)
It's gonna be a little
bit of a douchey answer
but it's the truth.
As a business leader, the one
thing that I most worry about
every day is my health.
Because the truth is, if I am healthy,
I am completely unscared of
any of the landscape or shifts,
definitely the competition,
internal issues,
like, I feel like I'm in complete control.
There is no place in the world
that I feel more completely
and utterly in control
than running a business.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
"center or edge?"
Daniel.
Edge.
- [Voiceover] Bill asks, "What's the
best way for a right hook
to seem like a jab?"
Bill, Bill, Bill, Bill, Bill.
Am I happy with you.
Because you've asked the
question that means so much to me
and is something that
so many of you are confused by.
Bill, I really appreciate you
and I'm not trying to sting,
but it might feel a little like that.
(laughs)
Trying to make a right
hook feel like a jab
is what 99% of salespeople
and businesses do
that end up failing.
It is in the clear honesty
and clear track of,
"when I want to do something
nice for you, I just do it,"
Ă la this show.
I just wanna take 15-20 minutes of my day
to share the God-given wisdom
and the work experience
and I want all of you to watch
it and I want this in return.
Now, come 15 months from
now, 18 months from now,
whether it's a book,
whether it's a seminar,
whether it's an event, whether
it's me selling rare toys,
who knows what it might be,
then I will clearly say,
"buy this friggin' rare toy,
it's $9.99. Buy it now."
But up until that point,
I will have very clear -
there'll be no show where
you're watching the show
and behind the scenes right
now there's subliminal music
pumping, "buy the damn cat for $9.99".
There is none of that.
And so there's a massive confusion
in the marketplace, Bill,
that people want to disguise the sale,
and there is no disguise.
Authentically. All in. All of it.
All in. Give when it's time to give.
On the flip side, there is
a crapload of Mother Teresas
and think it's so nice and awesome
and if you're just good, it's gonna - no.
You need to sell.
So when you sell, you say, I'm selling.
I am selling this. And I feel comfortable.
When I put a link out,
buy my book. It's out.
Buy it. If I've done
anything for you, buy it.
So, the answer to your
question is very simple.
There is no version of that.
That is a losing mentality and execution
and I highly recommend that you take it
and you split it very hard apart
where the jabs are clear
and where the right hooks are clear.
- [Voiceover] Jason asks, "how can a
public or government institution
use social media more effectively
in marketing campaigns,
i.e. to increase voter turnout?"
- Jason, the truth to that
answer is, believe it or not,
is to become more nimble and authentic.
There is no campaign
when there isn't the right process up top.
What I mean by that is, a lot
of government institutions
are coming from the wrong place.
For example,
I know that, you know, just
from a little politics,
and I don't talk politics very often,
but, like, that the Democratic Party
wants more voter turnout
and the Republican Party
historically has not.
These are little tidbits I've
picked up in the last 12 years
and I could be wrong about that,
they're just people in the game
that I've heard things like that.
So where are you coming
from is really the question.
I mean, to use social
to attract more voters,
the truth is, whether you're
a Republican or a Democrat,
you're trying to not recruit more voters,
you're trying to recruit more voters
that are gonna vote for you.
Right?
And so right there by its own definition,
you've got an interesting
kind of perplex situation
that the seed is tainted by the outcome.
And so to the best of one's ability,
I think it's important to try
to get the religion at the top
to really execute.
I mean, look,
social media is probably the
most consumer-insight-driven
marketing tool we've ever seen.
The data that you can
apply on top of social
to drive the results,
whether to get somebody
to vote for an election,
to buy a cat, to whatever it may be,
there's never been anything greater,
and so using, I've said it
before, Facebook dark posts,
with a combination of
Google long-tail search SEM,
can get you very, very, very far.
Guys, thank you so much
for watching Episode 8,
I really appreci-eight that,
and I'm gonna leave you with
this phenomenal Question of the Day:
What is your current favorite
single beverage?
Get specific in there.
I want to get to know you.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(heavy hip-hop music)
Picks the questions,
he picks the questions.
Show 'em, show 'em, show 'em, show 'em.